how much does David Foster Wallace mean
to you and didn't you actually use
something from his Kenyon College speech
at a critical point in your life yeah I
mean I am so I'm from Athens Georgia
which is a college town it's where the
University of Georgia is big indie rock
town like REM b-52s neutral milk hotel
bands like that and I started writing
for an alt weekly there when I was like
15 or 16 which was like around 95 96
everyone else they wrote for the paper
was a grad student or in a band locally
and they were obsessed with Wallace's
non-fiction which was getting published
everywhere at that point like shipping
out which was retitled supposedly fun
thing I'll never do again the cruise
ship SA and then when I started college
in the fall of 97 Infinite Jest come out
the previous year I got a copy I was an
English major every English major was
reading it or pretending to read it
using it as a doorstop something but it
was this you know monolithic thing that
you had to contend with if you're
interested in contemporary you know
literature this guy had written a 1079
page book what what is that I think was
and um it took me four or five months to
work my way through it but it was and I
felt pummeled by it I mean it's a book
that demands you invest in it it's not
an easy read but it's someone basically
saying I think you know how badly do you
want to get to know me and I felt at the
end of it that I'd found a friend like I
mean someone whose voice I wanted to
return to over and over there's a couple
of the writers for me like that like
Walker Percy or JD Salinger but I read
everything I could get my hands on from
Wallace his first collection of essays
came out that same year and then when I
was married had some of Wallace's
writing read at our wedding so yeah he
he was able to articulate things the way
that I wish I couldn't I think everybody
felt that way and talk about not just
you know academic things but the the
mundane junk food of life porn lobster
festival sports politics etc did that
make you a little hesitant in terms of
trying to make a movie based on David
Foster Wallace's words not his novel not
an adaptation but when you're so
enamored of an author is there a
hesitancy or reluctance on your part to
go there are you worried about what what
that author means do and how you're
going to make that into a movie you know
my only worry would be I mean I know my
intentions you know
which are always to try to understand
someone to come from a place of respect
and their judgment my concern would
always be my going to make a bad movie
you know as far as like the approach I
thought lipsky's book was stunning I
mean because it's david foster wallace
who was notoriously a private person but
wrote himself into a public life you
know by by writing by writing fiction by
profiling people by going on the charlie
rose show or things like that and
talking about his writing and this was
him at exactly the moment you know at
the tail end of the Infinite Jest book
to her that you know he was talking
about the themes of this book that would
define him he was okay you know being in
the you know in the company of a
journalist his mental health was in a
good place is addiction issues that were
in a good place he was teaching he was a
wonderful teacher this was I think films
that um deal with real lives you know
tend to deal with the high highs of the
low lows or that sort of the cradle to
the grave biopic that starts with a bee
sting and ends with a deathbed
confession right it's inherently
reductive because two hours is not
enough time this was a very very
subjective account from David Lipsky of
a few days that he spent with this guy
that he and admired and envied and how
he was affected by it I mean you didn't
have to deal with him being a writer or
going out of terror like pages going
through a typewriter you don't have to
deal with all the tropes of the genre
you could just set those all aside
because they're not part of the story
and I find those tropes to be really
tired just like I find the tropes of
addiction which is part of his life or
mental mental health issues which are
part of his life to be tired like I tend
to find them that they objectify and
reduce how complicated is to say wrestle
with depression or to write a
thousand-page book at the end of the day
to write a book that's over a thousand
pages you have to spend a lot of time in
front of your typewriter or computer and
say no to everything else and just work
and that's not dramatic to watch so when
we try to put that in a film the paint
splatter the tearing the page off I've
done it by God the end all those things
like that's that's not what get writer's
life is like most of the time it's much
more humbling it's real real craftsmen
like work so I was very happy to sort of
not go there at all David Lipsky is not
a minor journalist who's very successful
published book was a good magazine
writer there's a scene when he goes to
meet David Foster Wallace when he's
going to
trying to go to bed in his house and
he's surrounded by towers of his books
and I suspect what David lipsy is going
through knee might have talked to you
about this is that even though he was
successful he knew he would never be as
successful as David Foster Wallace yeah
I mean it's the ultimate phallic
nightmare right all those big tall tall
sexy books just looking down at you
shadowing you threatening to fall on you
and kill you um no I mean listen if
David Foster Wallace hadn't existed in
the first place David Lipsky at 30 would
have been one of the most successful
young writers in America his novel to
come out was in a claimed book not the
way Infinite Jest was but whose was you
know his collection of short stories I
mean his short stories ran in The New
Yorker they were great short stories
he's writing for Rolling Stone he was
very successful but you know his
experience I think is a very is the more
common one I think it's why the story is
not as inside baseball's it might seem
of just you know how someone interview
someone it's that you know everyone has
someone that they've admired from afar
or they've envied from afar they've AB
you know they've abstracted they
measured their own success against them
whether it's someone professionally
you've thought about or whether it's
just an estranged relative or an ex
boyfriend girlfriend we've all had that
person who looms large in our
consciousness they might not think about
us at all for one second of the day but
then you get that afternoon coffee with
them that you know that five minutes
with them and you have expectations of
what you want them to be and they're
just messy sloppy humans this the way we
all are and it's and they can't just fit
into the box that we want them to which
would be easier for us so as you're
thinking about what this movie really is
is it less about a journalist and a
subject less about the creative process
and how you talk about it is it more a
love story and maybe an unrequited love
story at that I think it's 'let onic
unrequited love story I've said it's
exactly that was exactly what I saw it
as I mean for me you know I thought of
Tony I mean I found a films like with
nil and I or midnight cowboy or
California split I thought about Amadeus
you know don't look back the da
Pennebaker documentary you know about
Bob Dylan right Bob Dylan yeah about the
way we you know we measure ourselves
against other people and and you know
there's great conflict in wanting
something from someone else that they
can't give you when you're listening to
the tapes themselves how much of it is
performance in other words obviously
somebody's trying to do a job and
somebody trying to seduce the other
person I don't
which one at which point but how much
are they performing for each other and
can you actually hear that when you're
listening to the audio tapes that lipsky
made it's interesting right i mean if
this was just a story about two old
college roommates or two brothers or
something would be a completely
different dynamic there would be more in
their natural state there was nothing
natural about this encounter it was an
incredibly um you know everything that
brought them there was highly surreal
and specific David lips could come to
write for a magazine that's published
internationally in cells ad space David
Foster Wallace had written a claim book
and had to sell it and also David Foster
Wallace was probably I mean he was for
my money wrote the best profiles of his
generation whether is a professional
athletes or John McCain they both knew
the game they both knew the other one
knew the game so in many ways they're
mirroring back to each other like both i
mean i think david foster wallace
genuinely wanted to make himself
vulnerable he knew that that would make
for the best article but he also didn't
want to become a parody of himself
either so i think the game playing that
was going on there was probably constant
and I don't I hopefully that's some of
the innate tension of the film I mean I
think it's hard to say whether Wallace
ever truly let his guard down with
Lipsky perhaps it was all some degree of
a performance I'm not sure what's Lipsky
involved in the making of the film and
were you free if he were to depict him
in the way you thought he had to be
depicted yeah Lipsky was amazing so I
mean Donald Margulies wrote this base on
lipsky's book and then talking to David
Lipsky he did not Donald did not listen
to the tapes the first time that I
talked to David Lipsky was a four hour
conversation and I think most
conversations with him are that large he
is an encyclopedic knowledge of
everything he's lightning quick Jesse
Eisenberg's doesn't look exactly what
really captures the essence of him and I
asked Lipsky if I could have the tapes
he gave them all to me I gave them to
the actors and then he just made himself
available in every way you know can we
come to your apartment can even can I
introduce you to a veek often our
casting director so she can look at you
and listen to you and he said yes to
everything and it's worth noting in his
book I think he's really tough on
himself in although of course you're not
becoming yourself it's him someone in
his 40s listen to himself at age 30
really trying to impress another guy and
fight to be the smartest person in the
room which you're probably not going to
be if you're in the room with David
Foster Wallace
and I think that book is infused with a
sense of regret and loss so I mean
Luke's kia has some humility about him
and but zero vanity like he was okay
with us being really tough on him I
think the film is tough and honest on
him as tough and honest as he was with
himself but he was very protective of a
David Foster Wallace of us getting the
details of his life right of us being
generous but the tiniest of things you
know no no he would not say this to like
one of the dogs he would he would talk
to them in this way he loved his dogs
you know things like that I mean this
was like at a script level and we just
picked his brain and he was great and we
showed him the movie before Sundance and
then he came to the sundance premiere
and yeah he's been really lovely